president Trump and councillor Tom  councilor general Tom we're here on  behalf of group of students young  professionals of Hong Kong the sincerely  pleas for emergent attention to what is  known as the extradition the g20 is a  platform for global leaders and experts  to discuss policies pertaining to the  promotion of national financial  stability recently they are series of  protests opposing the extradition bill  law the bill not only threatens Hong  Kong citizens but also Americans  residing and traveling in Hong Kong the  extradition bill does a major challenge  against human rights and freedom we hope  with the g20 360-degrees  multi-stakeholder approach and  independence from country specific  interests views will be on our side  Oh  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]